black history month is a time to
celebrate heroes who fought hard for
civil rights a lot of them are dead and
their stories are sad but i'd like to
take a minute out of black history month
to remember someone who is very much
alive zaila avangard she is the perfect
little sweetie who captured our hearts
not long ago by being the first
african-american to win the scripps
national spelling bee scrimps
yeah
and when she won she did this that is
correct
she is so cute twirling around like that
she was also named sports illustrated
sports kid of the year and she holds
three guinness world basketball records
she is an elite unicyclist and juggler
and i'm not making up any one of those
things these are all real things about
her so i just want to take a moment out
of our show to say that i think she is
amazing yeah
so
she she won the spelling bee huh um what
word
maria m-u-r-r-a-y-a
[Music]
m-u-r-r-a-y-a is how you spell you did
great
m-u-r-r-a-y-a
spells you got a lot on your plate
you're not really playing guitar i'm
nowhere near as talented as she is
[Music]
you got a bunch of world records cause
you're such a good athlete
once i attempted
to play a sport and i broke both my feet
i'm exaggerating but like barely
[Music]
m-u-r-r-a-y-a is how you spell good job
[Music]
m-u-r-r-a-y-a spells compared to you i'm
a slob what does that word even mean
i'm not as smart as that child
you've been doing your best to we're so
impressed we don't know where to start
when you twirl with joy i gotta say oh
boy it just fills up my heart
cool huh yeah she's really cool
m-u-r-r-a-y-a
it's how you spell it i think you're the
greatest
so ela's the greatest
we think you're the greatest
hey
hey
do you think she'll see this
she don't watch this show it's on past
her bedtime
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you